はい よろしくお願いします
恒例のことですが 今日もパワーポイントは使えないんです
まあ来月から私は持ってきます
えー まああの いろいろ書いておきたいことがたくさんありましたけど
とにかくできるだけ簡単にテーマに沿って話してみます
だからちょっと座ってます
あの ちょっとノートを見なくないと
今日のテーマはね 善行為はステップバイステップということで
で 一つ一つの達成感 で
これにいきなりあの ちょっと大胆にアクセスしてみようかなと思います
一般的に世の中では我々よく思っているのは
何でも早くて一発でやりたいんですね
で もう早くで一発でできるならばね
まあこんなありがたいことはないと思っていることは普通なんです
それからもの よく才能があるんだ
本当に能力があるんだとかね
よく言われる場合も だいたいこの早く一発でなんとかやるならば
その人に対してそういうことを言うんですね
しかし そういうことっていうのは世の中でできるんですかと
何でも早く一発で はい
大成功やっていうこと
こんなのはありえないんですよ
できるというのはほとんどないんだけど
私たちの心の中で この夢だけはあるんですね
できない人でも なんか夢だけを見るんですね
早く一発でできればいいんじゃないかなというね
この夢だけは消えませんね
それで 早くやりたい 早くやりたい
一発でやりたいという
この夢ばっかしに足引っ張られてどうなるのかというと
私たちは常に持っている能力さえも発揮できなくなるんです
で なぜかというと もう早くやりたいでしょ
だから焦って淡々とやろうとするんですよ
もう大失敗になるんです
大失敗したら どうせ能力があるということにならないでしょう
それで本人も いや こんな簡単なことはなんとことでしょうかと
ということで 悲しくなっちゃうんです
そういうことでも落ち込むことにもなります
これはどういうことでしょうかと
なんで人はいつでもあの
早くやりたくなるんですかね
まあ早くやりたくなるのはいいんだけど
何でも一発でやろうとするんですかね
それはあんまり誰も考えないんですね
なんで私たちはもう仕事っていうのは淡々と段取りを沿って順番にやりたくはないんです
一発でやりたい どういうことですかね
それは それはこの 我々は本当のところは怠け者なんです
ものすごい怠け者なんです
で しかし 誰一人も私は怠け者だと言わないのはいいんだけど
認めたくもないんです
他人で別にいくら責めてもいいんです
まあ最低自分で認めるぐらい心の中で内緒でもね
内緒で認めることさえもしないんです
それで このポイントよく覚えてください
今日はそれがほとんどの種になります
人は怠け者っていうところ
これ人はといっても 大体生命は誰でもという意味なんです
だから別に落ち込まなくてもいいんです
生命は誰でも怠け者なんです
特別に皆様方に言ってるわけじゃないんです
で 怠け者ですが 認めて認めたくはないんです
それでもいくら怠け者であっても
我々にはあらゆる様々な仕事をしなくちゃいけないんですよ
最低 動物の場合はね 餌を探すことも仕事で
人間の場合ももうそれも仕事で
料理作ることも仕事で
食べることも後片付けも何でもかんでも仕事なんですね
そういうやらなくちゃいけないことは次から次へとたくさんあるんです
こういうことをやっていると
怠け者だから本体 本当はできればやめたいという希望があるんです
動物もそうなんですよ
この獲物取ったりするでしょ
できればやめたいんです
でもやめたっても自分が死んでしまいますから
お腹が空いて だから嫌々嫌で獲物を追っていくんですよ
あのテレビのいろいろ
動物チャンネルやら NHK の自然の番組でも見てください
肉食動物は一生懸命餌を取ろうと頑張っているんですけど
ほとんど失敗するんですね
そう簡単にうまく獲物取れないんです
なぜかというと まあ怠け者だからいい加減なんですよ
自分の命がかかっているのに
ですから怠け者だから仕事に集中しないんですね
手抜きするんです 中途半端になるんです
早く終わりたい 結果を出したいだけで
すべてが中途半端なんです
こういうことで我々は自分を騙しているということがあるんです
これには誰も気づかないんです
それは初めて言うのも仏教だけなんです
生命っていうのは 自分で自分を騙しているんだと
だからずっと昔なる過去から騙しているんだから気づくはずもないんです
これ なまじ一つの騙しなんです
はい それで矛盾が生まれてくるんですね
だって怠けたければ怠ければいいのに
怠けるわけにはいきませんね
虎が獲物を取りたくはないんだけど
獲物を狙わないわけではうまくいかないんですね
だからそこで矛盾が生まれるんですよ
仕事も中途半端になるし
で 人にはたくさん矛盾があります
まあ私たち人間にとっては
またすごいたくさん矛盾がありますよ
どちらかというと いつでも骨肉建物２つありますから
これまた随分違うんですね
はっきり言えば この経典に丸ごとで信頼できないのは人間だと
動物だったら大丈夫だと
怒ったらわかります もうすごい楽しく
動物はすごい楽しいんだったらもうわかるんです
動物が人を信頼すると
もうはっきりしているんです
信頼したら信頼なんです
そこら辺で矛盾はないんです
動物の矛盾はこの怠けるだけなんですね
怠けたいんだけど 怠けるわけにはいきませんという矛盾だけなんです
人間にとってはすごい
もうどこまででも矛盾なんです
だから人間は人を信頼すると言っても
それはもう当てにならない
言うことも当てにならない
だから これすごいたくさん大量の矛盾を人間だけは持ってます
それで怠けたいから努力しますと
大きな矛盾ですから それもすごい大きな矛盾で
社会全体的に見える矛盾は怠け矛盾の結果なんです
この世界 社会全体じゃなくて世界全体なんです
一番皆様が今ぶつかっている矛盾というのは
この自然破壊なんですね
あの温暖化っていうのは
あれは嘘で あの儲かるためにやってるからくりで
別に大げさな問題じゃないんです
自然破壊が問題なんです
資源がこういう争っていることは問題なんです
飲む水がなくなっていることが問題なんです
一度ぐらい地球の温度が上がったんだからといって
どうしたこともないんです
あれは一部の人間の商売人です
すごくいいことですよ
だったら何億も何 100億も使っても
地球の温度はね  0.1度も下がりません
我々は冷房を我慢して
暖房を我慢して 温度下がると思う？何考えてるんですかね
科学者のくせに それだったらあっちこっちむちゃくちゃ木を植えておけばどうですかね
どこででも 海の上ででも
何かフォーティンガーデンみたいなものを作っちゃえばどうですかね
で 浮きように何とか台を作って
そちらに土を入れて まあそこでガーデン作っちゃうと
そんなことは思ったりもしないでしょ
科学だからね 変なことを考えるのは科学者の世界なんです
まあとにかく 今我々はこの自然破壊という問題にぶつかっています
なんでその問題が出たかというと
この矛盾の問題なんですね
とにかく怠けたい だから壊したい放題壊す
後の結果考えません ある会社が自分が儲かりたいだけで好き勝手に値段を上げたりする
する品物の そうするともうどんどん儲かるぞと
そうじゃないんです 買う人のお金がなくなっちゃいますから
一回買ったら それでお金がないんだからと会社倒産しなくちゃいけないんです
それってずっと見てるでしょうに
そして誰かが何か新しいものを発見すると
それはどうせ売れるでしょうね
いきなりみんな恐縮で同じものを作るんです
日本の状況どうですかね
誰かが何か作っちゃうと
100種類同じものできているんです
名前だけ違って これで倒産するでしょうに
買う人にとっても信頼性がないでしょうに
あまりにもありすぎだから
まあもうラベルと中身はまた違う
で 結構私はいろんな品のラベルは読むんです
それは別にどうしたことなくて
ちょっと趣味みたいなものなんです
全部読む 読むとよく発見することは
誰もこの箱に書いているものは中身で約束を守っているとはないんです
その中身のものを飲んだら
食べたらこうこうなります
それは書きません  昨日ちょっと店に行って
店の中で何とかいいビタミン何百三なんとかなんだらかんだらとかね
書いてるだけで この中身はそういう風に入ってるとか言えないんです
だからまあ面白いんです
えーと それで経済成長すると貧困が増える
で 経済成長すると 成長した人々にもどんどん息苦しくなる
で 社会は発展するとアトピーは出てくるわ
あらゆるアレルギーは出てくるわ
生きていられなくなる
喘息は増えるわ いつでもそういう矛盾というもの
どこでも政治 経済 学校
会社 家庭内 どこでも矛盾でしょ
この矛盾がないところっていうのはないんです
一つも聞くと 一つどーんとダメになっちゃう
一度は人間 これに気づかないんですよ
よく記事まで書くんですよ
エコロジーと経済発展というのは両立できるのかどうか
日本語でもあるでしょう
英語ではあって読んだことはありますけど
このバランス取れますかと
経済成長とエコロジー
自然を守ること だからこの
これはちっちゃな問題じゃないんですよ
人類の問題なんです この心の中に怠けというものがあるんです
そこを隠してる限りは
人類の救いはないんです
誰もそれ見つからないんです
面白いこと だから皆様は揃って
もうものすごく勢い 気合を入れて仏教を学ばなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから仏教も聞いただけで心の中に入りません
この壁が厚いんです 原子爆弾を落としても壊れないぐらいの厚い無知の壁があるんです
だから かなり強烈に聞いて
心の中になんとか入れておかないと
幸福の世界が現れないんです
だから もう徹底的に直接に真理を語るのはお釈迦様だけ
それにも訳がありまして
今日の講演の最後にそれを説明します
どんな開発計画にも悪い結果も結果も付いているんですね
それから次の問題は 思考の怠けというものがあるんです
怠け者は何するかというと妄想するんです
楽でしょ あても わけもなく
目的もなく 理屈も理論も何のこともなく
ただ妄想する 怠けがあるから
論理的に具体的に考えることもどこかで脱線して間違ってしまいます
だから人間の思考も基本的に間違っています
私ももうちょっと若かったらこんな大胆なこと言いませんだけど
今もう怖いものないんです
もう寿命が短いんだからね
一応本当のことを何のことなくも言うんです
なかなか私に対して挑戦できる知識人にいまだかつて会ったことがないんです
まあ肩書きいっぱいもう 1キロぐらい持ってる人々はよく知ってますけど
何か私喋りだすとかなり尻込みをするんです
ですから まあ言わなくちゃいけないんです
思考そのものが間違っているんです
これがこの怠けという思考の怠けってことなんです
脱線するんですよ まあ例えば
ちょっとわかりやすい例えで考えましょう
で 何かを会社で まあこれ調べなさいとか何とか言われたとする
で 一生懸命データ取ったり
あちこちからもう調べていると
もうやっぱりやりたくないんですね
そうすると 誰かさんももっと前にそういうことを調べたことがあって
まあまあ途中で会社辞めたとか見つかったら
そのままそれ取っちゃうんです
取って出すんです  日本語でいうカニング
英語でいうチーティングですね
何のことなくやっちゃいます
あるいは新しい品物を開発しようと言うと
その人々はみんな一人一人責任を持って考えなくちゃいけないでしょ
でも怠けだからリーダーがいるんだから
どうしてもリーダーが必要でしょうし
この開発 えーと 何て言いますか
コミュニティの それでリーダーが何か言ったら
はいはい その通りにしましょう
いきなりそれに乗る 誰かの考えに乗る
みんなやるよりやるが
自分自身にひらめきはない
ちょっと読みにくい感じ選んだんです
だから怠け ちょっと抑えて読んでください
でもどうしても知ってほしいものはわかりやすい文字に変えているんです
新しいアイディアがっていうか
発見で現れないんですね
みんな悩んでるんですよ
なかなかアイディアが現れないなとか
あれ 怠けなんです 一人何かない？って一人で困るんです
私はもう本当にもう巻き上げしていますよ
もう私からいろんなアイディアを聞くは聞く
どこまで聞くの？もう可哀想だから
聞いたら一応こうすればどうですか
こうすればどうですかね
言うんだけど 私は出家であって
仏教以外何も学んでないし
もう会社に行ったことがないし
結婚もしたことがないし
だからもう知るわけないでしょ
そこ世間のこと それでもなんで私が何かアドバイス出したら
それはもうぴったし100%はめるんですかね
たった違いはたった 1個です
怠けがあるんです だから心は動かないんです
で 今私はかなり脳細胞衰えてますけど
その前っていうのはものすごい
いつでもどれだけでも行ったり来たり
行ったり来たり 何のこともない
だからこの怠けということが大きな問題で
人間には能力がなくて
ひらめきが出てこない
新しいアイディアが出てこないとかね
それで頑張ってますよ
それでもいろいろ研究したり
いろんなことをしたりは頑張ってはいるんですけど
よく疲れますね 研究したりしたりすると
データ調べたり 並べ替えたり集めたりする
かなり疲れるでしょ あれは怠けだからなんです
あまりにも疲れると どこかでやりたくはないということはずっとあるんです
何やってもご飯食べるために
ご飯3杯は作ってくれますけど
米を研ぐことでもあんたやりたいのに絶対やりたくない
だから無洗米という  笑い
毒が入ってるものを売っているんです
あれを堂々と買って食べるんです
おそらく私も食べてるでしょうね
店から買って食べてるんだから
だからいかに怠けかというね
この怠け病で ものすごく我々が脳の怠け入っちゃうと
もう新しいアイデアは何も出てこないんです
もう言っておきますけど
この世の中で常に新しいものがないと成り立たないんです
キリスト教 イスラム教ですと
原始時代に戻そうとしているのは
原始時代には戻れません
とにかくどうにもならん
先へ先へと進むしかないんです
選択はないんです 昨日の生き方で今日は生きていられません
だから昨日のことの繰り返してワンパターンでやりましょうと思って失敗してるでしょう
私はいつでも出す まあいい加減な例なんですけど
で 結婚した途端 なんで最初の 1週間で新郎さんとお嫁さんがぶつかるんですかね
新郎さんが今までのパターンで生きていられると思ってるんですね
できるわけないでしょう
お嫁さんもお嫁さんで
自分の家で怠け者で大怠け者で
もう母親にご飯作ってもらって
食って寝るだけで 父親も何も言いません
娘はすごい可愛いんだから
なんて若い娘が家でうろうろうろうろしてるのは
父親にとってはものすごい可愛いんです
結婚してもそのまま行くと思ってるんです
1 日で人生変わりますよ
1 日で だから我々はもう昨日の生き方で今日生きていられないということ
物事はもうずっと変わって変わっていくんです
だから進むしかないんです
この世の中は あれに文句言って
これに文句 それでもう怠け
文句言うしかないんです
だからこの そういう能力が必要なんです
そのどうしても必要な能力はないんですね
だから別は例えば人間っていうのは算数を
済まなくちゃいけないでしょうね
酸素がないんだというと
これってすごい大きな問題でしょう
生命には日々使うひらめきが必要なんです
それがないんです 今 いろいろひらめきある人間がいて
それで世界はなんとか成り立ってはいるんだけど
そういう人々っていうのは
ものすごい四苦八苦の上で
なんとかなにか作り出すんです
はい それでは 一つのテーマは
思考...